hi david uh this is mike from uh
washington state
i was wondering if you could answer a
question for me i hear
um you occasionally refer to
trump supporters as sick of fans or sick
offense
i'm not really sure what that means or
what that i kind of know what it means
but i don't really know what
you're saying is it sick of fans or
sika fans or
you know i'm not really sure what that
term is
being said there so if you could clear
that up for me i appreciate it i'll talk
to you later
okay so the term is sycophant okay it's
s-y-c-o-p-h-a-n-t
a sycophant is someone who acts
obsequiously
towards someone important in order to
gain
advantage or gain perceived advantage
what does obsequious mean obsequious is
to be obedient or attentive to an
excessive or servile degree so when we
talk about trump sycophants
we're talking about the people who will
go with anything trump says trump says i
i deserve a third term because my first
one i had to deal with impeachment
they go with it they are completely
non-discriminating
in terms of what they will agree with
trump on and they do it
in order to gain some perceived
advantage either it's we want trump to
like us or it's to be part of the
in crowd or it's because what our family
and friends expect us to do or whatever
the case may be so the word is sycophant
and often i like to sort of dress it up
by calling them
brown-nosing sycophants but maybe that's
a topic for another day
we've got a great bonus show for you
today donald trump is now lashing out at
new zealand's coronavirus response
on a day when new zealand had nine
coronavirus cases we're going to talk
about
new zealand because it's very
interesting what's going on there
we also have reported 130 degree
temperatures in death valley
potentially record temperatures coming
in death valley
and in california more than 3 million
homes
could lose power i will tell you why and
what's going on and we'll talk about
energy solar and much much more we've
got a great bonus show coming up for you
today get instant access to it
two ways become a member at
joinpackman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i'll see you then